The court next takes up the question of whether the death penalty is appropriate
for certain people who commit crimes.
Uh,
in,
uh,
the Henry Case,
the court,
uh,
and the Atkins case,
the court looks at whether the death pony is constitutionally,
uh,
appropriate for a person whose intellectual,
intellectually disabled.
Uh,
at the time these cases were decided.
This was generally referred to as mental retardation.
And that's the language that's in the court's opinion.
And that's the language mental retardation,
uh,
that we see in many of the statutes.
Uh,
this,
uh,
when we talk about intellectual disability or a mental retardation,
we're talking about a person who has substantially sub average intellectual
functioning that is somebody who tests low on an intelligent quotient test,
usually 70,
75,
somewhere in that neighborhood or,
or below,
um,
that the person,
uh,
has that in deficits in two or more areas of adaptive behavior that is in terms
of the person doing the day to day things that all people do,
uh,
in their lives,
that they have deficits in handling things,
making change,
uh,
other,
other things like that.
And finally that it was manifested before the age of 18.
This appears in the Atkins case at converses for genuine footnote number three,
where the court gives the definition of both the American psychiatric
association as well as the American psychological association.
There slight differences in the language,
but basically this is the description,
uh,
of,
mental retardation or intellectual disability,
uh,
that the court uses.
Uh,
now this is interesting in terms of how,
uh,
the consensus as the court finds it develops.
1987,
not a single state,
prohibited the death penalty for the intellectually disabled.
Uh,
by 1989,
two states,
Georgia,
which was the first state to prohibited and Maryland and the United States,
which had adopted the death penalty in 1988 had excluded mental retarded people
from those eligible for the death pony.
Then we'd come in at 2002,
which is when the Atkins case is decided.
Now,
18 states have held that the death penalty is not appropriate for intellectually
disabled people.
And the court looks at those 18 states,
and this is the difference between the majority of the court and the descending
opinion.
It also adds in the 12 states that don't have the death pony.
So it reaches a,
and of course,
the United States government's still doesn't have it.
Uh,
so the majority adds this up and says this is 30 states.
Notice this is not nearly as overwhelming as in coker.
We had 49 states.
Uh,
only one state had it in 49 states didn't,
or Kennedy versus Louisiana where a handful of states had it in 44 states.
Uh,
did not,
uh,
here,
we reached,
uh,
the court reaches a total of 30 states.
Uh,
but that's counting,
uh,
the 12 states that don't have the death penalty at all.
Uh,
the dissenters argue that the states without the death penalty should not be
counted.
A,
the courts should only look at the states that have the death penalty.
Uh,
and based on that,
uh,
the,
this is not constitutionally prohibited.
The question here,
just whether the death penalty is categorically barred for someone who meets the
definition,
uh,
of intellectual disability,
um,
that Supreme Court,
uh,
talks here as it will be talking about in other situations.
As with children.
Uh,
how do we minimize the risk?
Once we sort of survey the states?
We see 30 to 20 according to the majority,
and the majority also points out that in the 20 that that allow imposition of
the death pony.
It's very infrequently imposed upon people who are intellectually disabled.
Uh,
and then it sees factors that,
uh,
run the possibility or the risk that a person who is intellectually disabled
might be sentenced to death,
uh,
inappropriately,
that,
uh,
such people are less able to assist their lawyers,
and preparing and working on their case,
uh,
there,
less able to,
uh,
put on mitigating circumstances because again,
they may not have the intellectual,
uh,
capabilities of working with their lawyer and developing the evidence as a,
as a person,
uh,
who,
who was not intellectually disabled would be able to,
uh,
they're less able to testify.
Uh,
the court says they are typically very poor witnesses.
threat of false confessions.
Uh,
the court looks to the Earl Washington case.
This is a fellow with a very low Iq or a Washington who confessed to a number of
crimes and was convicted and sentenced to death,
almost executed.
Uh,
but then governor wilder and Virginia commuted his sentence to life in prison.
And then sometime after that with the developments in DNA testing,
uh,
it was shown that Earl Washington was absolutely innocent,
had absolutely nothing to do with the case,
even though he had confessed to doing it,
but he was intellectually disabled,
very susceptible to suggestion and very willing to go along with authority
figures in saying that he had done something,
uh,
even though he had not in the court notes that,
in a footnote,
the court also talks about the unwarranted,
uh,
impression,
that,
uh,
the jury may have that a person lacks remorse,
if they're a intellectually disabled.
And this may be because,
uh,
the person just simply doesn't have the intellectual capability of following the
complex proceedings in the court.
And so sits there,
uh,
looking sort of cold and unfeeling when in fact they're just not able to process
the information that's coming into their mind.
At the time.
This is going on.
Uh,
so the court decides that the death penalty is unconstitutional for people who
are intellectually disabled.
Uh,
then the court has over time,
uh,
looked at the question of the death pony for children,
in 1988 and Thompson versus Oklahoma.
Uh,
the Supreme Court does divided four votes one way,
four votes.
The other justice O'Connor making the critical decision that at least Oklahoma
could not put 15 year old,
uh,
children.
And we're talking about when the crime was committed.
That is a child who committed a crime at age 15,
not eligible for the death poem,
but then the court and Stanford,
uh,
versus Kentucky in 1989,
upheld the death penalty,
uh,
for children who were 16 and 17 years of age.
And that was the law for some time and a number of children that age or who
committed their crimes when they were that age were sentenced to death and,
and a number were executed.
Uh,
despite the Stanford case,
the Missouri Supreme Court decides in the Semans case,
uh,
that the death penalty is unconstitutional for those under 18.
At the time of the crime.
So how can the court do that?
Uh,
the Missouri Supreme Court goes out on a limb just a bit saying that based on
Atkins,
we think if the supreme court were to reconsider this decision,
uh,
it would overrule Stanford and it would prohibit a,
the death penalty for people under who commit crimes when they're under 18 years
of age.
Well,
the,
the Missouri Supreme Court,
uh,
certainly forced the court's hand,
to make a decision about whether it was going to overrule it's previous decision
or not.
Uh,
but ultimately,
uh,
the court does affirm in the Simmons case,
Roper Versus Simmons,
uh,
and decides that the death pony is unconstitutional for anyone who commits a
crime when they're under 18 years of age.
Uh,
just as in a Atkins,
that's the mental retardation case.
18 states prohibited the death pony for people under 18 at the time of the
crime.
Uh,
12 states of course don't have the death pony at all.
and then you have 20 states that authorize the death pony.
But as the court points out,
the use of the death penalty in those states is infrequent.
And it points out that in particular,
uh,
the governor of Kentucky,
committed,
uh,
Kevin Stanford,
the,
the person who was the named party in Stanford,
uh,
versus the court,
notes that the governor of Kentucky commutes a sentence and it says,
we're not going to execute someone who was a child at the time the crime was
committed.
So it finds that the use is infrequent,
even in the states that have it.
Uh,
and this,
the court says is sufficient evidence that society views juveniles as
categorically less culpable than the average person.
In other words,
that someone who commits a crime under the age of 18,
while guilty of murder,
while certainly can be prosecuted as an adult,
can be punished severely even sentenced to life imprisonment without any
possibility of parole,
but that that person cannot be sentenced to death.
Part of it is looking at the states again,
30 to 20,
not nearly the almost unanimity opinion that we saw,
a unanimity of,
uh,
views that we saw in the coker case.
Uh,
but the same exactly,
uh,
that we saw in the Atkins case.
Uh,
but then,
uh,
of course took a lot of evidence in this case on and got briefs from experts on
the development of brains and young people and adolescents and people growing
up,
uh,
and found,
as most parents would probably know already,
uh,
that the,
brain development of someone who's 16,
17,
18 years of age,
uh,
has not,
or the brain of that person is not fully developed.
Uh,
and that at that point,
people do not have as good a ability to make decisions,
to make good judgments and so forth.
Uh,
so the court looks at,
uh,
at this factor and compare sort of the intellectually disabled and the children,
both having an under underdeveloped sense of responsibility.
The court says,
uh,
in addition to that,
both are vulnerable as we talked about just a moment ago with regard to the
intellectually disabled.
Uh,
both are vulnerable to negative influences and outside pressures that as they
can be led into doing things that they normally wouldn't do,
but because they're immature or because they're intellectually limited,
uh,
they might get caught up in something,
they do not make good decisions,
uh,
due to their intellectual limitations.
Or as I talked to him about a moment ago,
the lack of development,
the lack of,
uh,
of their brain or what we would call it maturity,
they have less control over their environment.
Uh,
children really don't have much choice whether they live,
uh,
have the good fortune to be born into a wealthy,
loving a home or whether they happen to grow up in a domestic war zone,
uh,
where everyone is an abject poverty and where there's a,
a lot of violence and killing and gang activity and so forth.
So,
uh,
that is a factor that,
the court finds militates in favor of prohibiting the death penalty for four
children.
Uh,
and finally the court says the juvenile a character is not well formed and
therefore,
uh,
because of that,
children are less couple,
but again,
not saying they can't be convicted of murder,
but just saying in terms of whether we impose the ultimate punishment,
uh,
again,
as an Atkins,
we're concerned about,
uh,
risk.
Uh,
the court says here,
the difference between juveniles and adult offenders are so marked and well
understood that we can't risk allowing a youthful person to receive the death
penalty even though that person's not sufficiently.
A couple of them.
Uh,
and the court points out that it's difficult even for an expert in child
behavior,
a psychologist,
uh,
to differentiate between the immature,
child and the,
what he calls the irreparably corrupt child.
Uh,
and finally,
an unacceptable likelihood exists that the brutality of the crime will overpower
the mitigating circumstances.
This is a,
uh,
questionable in controversial a reason a given in the case because of course,
this is true in almost every death penalty case that the horrific nature of the
crime,
uh,
may be,
more overpowering than whatever evidence in mitigation is submitted.
Uh,
but in cases where a person is young,
they don't have as much of a life and background as somebody who is older.
Uh,
and perhaps that's what justice Kennedy was thinking about here.
then he looks at the purpose of punishment,
a retribution.
Uh,
the death penalty is our most severe punishment.
And the question is,
do we impose it on someone who's blame worthiness is diminished,
still blame worthy,
but diminished blame worthiness due to their youth and then to Terrance,
uh,
is deterrent served.
And the court finds that because children don't have the same ability to process
information,
to learn from their mistakes,
to consider,
uh,
to make good judgments and considered the wisdom of what they're doing.
Uh,
unlike adults,
uh,
that the purpose of punishment is not being served by allowing people who commit
crimes under the age of 18 to be sentenced to death.
Uh,
justice O'Connor,
uh,
would ask a very different question here.
And it's interesting,
she was voted for banning the death pony for people who are intellectually
disabled,
but she dissents from this decision in her view.
The question here is whether by virtue of youth alone,
the defendant in [inaudible] lacks the cognitive vocation of volitional and
moral capacity to act with a degree of culpability that we associate with the
death penalty.
Uh,
in other words,
she would,
uh,
treat each person individually.
She said there can be a 17 old,
but when you look at the background and life of that person,
that person is sufficiently culpable that we should give them the death pony.
We may have an 18 year old who is immature and perhaps not appropriate for the
death penalty,
but she would sort it out person by person.
Uh,
because she says,
youth alone does not always mean.
Now,
the majority responds to this by saying,
we,
we can see this point,
but we're worried about the risk.
We're worried about the risk of somebody who's culpability is not as great as
other offenders.
Uh,
receiving the death.
Pollock,
uh,
O'connor writes only for herself,
in her dissent.
Uh,
Justice Scalia on the other hands joined by the chief justice and Justice
Thomas.
Uh,
he says that,
first of all,
we shouldn't count the states without the death pony.
This is the point he'd made earlier.
And Atkinson.
He makes,
again,
we should only look at the states that have the death plan on the books and see
how many would allow the death pony for those under 18 at the time of the crime
and how many do not.
Uh,
he accuses the majority of bringing their personal views into the analysis,
uh,
which of course would probably not be agreed to by,
by the majority of the court.
Uh,
but then he also criticizes the studies that are cited in the majority opinion.
He points out,
there was no evidentiary hearing in Roper on this question where this was
subject to any kind of adversarial testing.
That is where doctors testified and we're cross-examined and doctors on both
sides testified.
And the court made some finding,
uh,
with regard to the development of the brains of children and the other issues
that were before the court.
He accuses the court of looking out over the crowd,
uh,
and picking out it's friends and other words,
making very selective use of evidence to reach the conclusion,
uh,
that the death pony is not appropriate.
Uh,
he also,
um,
uh,
looks and tries to discredit the American psychological association,
which has filed a brief where the courts saying,
uh,
that,
children,
uh,
who are 17,
17,
and 16,
at the time of the crime are immature,
uh,
don't make good judgments and so forth.
He points out that that same association filed a brief where the court that said
at age 14 and 15 children could make a decision about having an abortion.
Uh,
he also points out that,
uh,
article 37 of the convention of the rights of a child,
which is decided by the majority,
uh,
it does prohibit the death plenty for this class of people.
But the United States in Somalia,
the only two states,
uh,
only two countries in the world have not ratified it.
So he said,
how could this possibly be the consensus of the United States or even relevant
to the views of people in the United States,
uh,
when it hasn't even been ratified by the Senate?
Uh,
he believes very strongly that the laws of other countries,
uh,
should not be considered a,
and he accused as the court of citing the laws and other countries selectively
when it makes those decisions.
What the majority had done has made its analysis of the states,
how many allowed the death penalty for this group of children and how many did
not,
uh,
it and then looked at the risk,
of,
uh,
the death plenty being imposed despite diminished culpability.
Only after that the court had said,
and our opinion is confirmed by the fact that other countries in the world,
uh,
do not,
allowed us,
uh,
but it didn't really say it based its decision on.
And it just simply pointed to the fact that other countries didn't allow it.
But this is a controversial point.
It's a point that comes up and,
um,
uh,
confirmation hearings when people are nominated to the supreme court.
Will you follow international law or will you only followed domestic law?
Only follow the law of the United States.
Uh,
but as the world becomes a more globalized and as we all intend to interact with
other countries and so forth,
uh,
that may be a,
that view at least can be questioned,
is somewhat a provincial that we might look to other places,
uh,
and find out what they've done and learn from that.
Well,
there were two important decisions that flowed from,
uh,
this decision by the Supreme Court.
Uh,
the first one was Graham versus Florida.
This is not a death penalty case,
but this is a child in Florida had a number of these children who were sentenced
to life imprisonment without any possibility of parole,
uh,
that committed crimes where no one was killed.
Uh,
Joe Sullivan case that was argued with the gram case,
uh,
where in a one day trial,
a 13 year old child is convicted and sentenced to life imprisonment without any
possibility of parole,
no matter how well that child does in prison,
uh,
or as an adult,
that person does in prison,
uh,
no consideration whatsoever.
The Supreme Court says this is disproportionate and,
and excessive,
uh,
for a child.
And it looks basically at its death penalty,
uh,
decisions.
And it looks particularly at what had decided in roper about the development of
the brains of children,
about children's in maturity,
uh,
their ability to make decision and it decides that,
this is too excessive or two severe punishment,
uh,
for,
for those children.
Uh,
and then the court decides Miller versus Alabama.
this is decided in 2012,
uh,
and this involved again,
life imprisonment without any possibility of parole,
but for homicide cases,
the fault the court finds,
the challenge Miller made and the other person who were two cases here,
one out of Arkansas and one out of a Alabama.
And the challenge was that in these cases,
life without the possibility of parole was automatic.
That once a person was convicted of this crime,
once someone under 17 or younger was convicted of this crime,
the judge had no discretion,
but the death plenty was mandatory.
The court says you can't do that.
It has to be individualized sentencing.
Hearing where the judge takes into account the child's age circumstances of the
crime and other mitigating factors.
It doesn't mean that a court can't,
after taking all those into account a sentence,
a child to a very long sins or even probably life imprisonment without the
possibility of parole,
but it says that the court has to,
it can't do it automatically.
The legislature cannot provide that if you do a certain crime.
Uh,
they can,
they can provide that for adults,
but not for these children that if you do a certain crime,
it's automatically going to be life imprisonment without any possibility of
parole.
So two significant decisions because the court has done very little on the
question of proportionality outside the area of the death penalty.
Um,
finally we come to individual proportionality review.
This is a different kind of question we've looked at whether the penalty is
appropriate for the role of the offender and the crime we've looked to her,
whether it's appropriate for certain crimes and for certain kinds of offenders,
children,
an intellectually disabled people.
Now,
Robert Dalton Harris,
who was sentenced to death in California,
comes before the court and he's got a different argument.
He says,
I want a determination of whether the death pony was disproportionate in my case
compared to all the other murder cases.
And the senses imposed in California.
And the basis for this argument is that when the Supreme Court upheld a Georgia
statute in 1976 in the case of Greg versus Georgia,
it pointed out when and lauded the fact that the Georgia Supreme Court under
that statute was required to compare each case to others and see if the death
pony was disproportionate,
considering both the circumstances of the crime,
uh,
and the background of the offender.
And so some people read the Supreme Court's opinion,
uh,
in,
Greg to say that this was constitutionally required course.
The court also upheld,
uh,
the Texas statute that day where there was no such provision in the statute.
Florida had decided judicially to conduct proportionality review,
but it was not in the statute upheld in 1976.
Well,
the court decides,
uh,
that,
the eighth amendment does not require the proportionality review that Harris
has.
Seeking.
Harris wants to say what I did was murder,
but somebody else committed a murder far more heinous than mine.
They didn't get the death pony,
therefore,
I shouldn't get the death by a Supreme Court says California doesn't have to do
that.
That California has limited the death penalty to a small sub class of people by
requiring the consideration and special factors.
What we've previously talked about as aggravating circumstances.
In other words,
this is much like what the court said in Zant versus Stevens when it upheld the
Georgia law and said that what Georgia did with it's aggravating circumstance
was narrow.
The class of eligibles narrow the people who are eligible for the death penalty.
And that's really all the eighth amendment,
uh,
requires.
Uh,
the jury's a discretion is limited,
uh,
by being directed to particular factors that say these factors weigh in favor of
the death plenty or,
or,
or these do not.
Uh,
so the result of this case,
uh,
is quite significant,
because a number of states that had proportionality review statutes immediately
repeal them.
Uh,
and a number of states that still had it on the books,
quit doing proportionality review,
Georgia being one of them.
Georgia had actually found some death sentences.
The Georgia Supreme Court disproportionate,
uh,
before this decision.
Uh,
but after this decision,
it has yet to find a death since,
uh,
disproportionate.
Uh,
so once again,
we,
we conclude here with the fact that the court takes a much narrower view of what
the eighth amendment to the United States constitution,
what the cruel and unusual punishment clause requires.
In the 1976 cases,
the court was talking about the discretion of the sensor being guided by clear
and objective standards.
Here the court is simply saying,
as long as you narrow the class,
as long as the state narrows,
the class says,
only people who commit murder them and commissioner of an arm robbery or murder
the commissioner with kidnapping or however the court,
uh,
the state,
excuse me,
defines it's aggravating circumstance.
As long as that narrows the group of people that can be considered.
That's all the eighth amendment requires.
So that means Robert Holden Harris,
uh,
does not get a review of his case compared to others.
He was put to death by the state of California.
Uh,
and it means that,
uh,
while there are some states and Florida is one example of a state that still
conducts proportionality review and the farthest supreme court does,
and this is not the only state,
but the Florida Supreme Court does from time to time find that the death Connie
is disproportionate.
It looks at other states,
excuse me,
other cases in the state,
uh,
what punishment was imposed a and it builds some law there by its decisions in
terms of when the death plan is appropriate and when it's not.
That provides some guidance to prosecutors and Florida and also to trial judges
about when the death penalty is appropriate and when it's not.
But that's not the case in most states.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in the individual proportionality review can be done as a matter of state law,
but it's not required by the constitution of the United States.